for so many Notre Dame Cathedral was a
place where they could go in times of
trouble and it was heartbreaking to
watch that religious symbol burn
yesterday in Paris but they've already
vowed to rebuild and they're gonna do it
with a Hollywood connection the world
looked on in horror as flames brought
down the Notre Dame spire and much of
the roof but against all odds
Paris's beloved Cathedral is still
standing prayers and pledges to rebuild
are now coming in from all over the
world share a Juris Alba laura dern in
Anne Hathaway all took to social media
reacting to the fire Salma Hayek's
husband French billionaire onry Francois
Pino has pledged an astounding 113
million dollars Pinos family is worth an
estimated 35 billion dollars they own a
slew of Couture brands including Gucci
Saint Laurent and Alexander McQueen
Salman onry raised their 11 year old
daughter Valentina our time in Paris
sama posted this image with the caption
quote I'm in deep shock and sadness to
witness the beauty of no tree Dom turn
into smoke I love you Paris no tree dam
isn't just an iconic Parisian landmark
it is also served as the backdrop for
many Hollywood productions like Sawa's
1997 TV movie The Hunchback 2017 s
Beauty and the Beast want to see
finished look Dom 2011 s Midnight in
Paris
[Music]
ketta and Ethan Hawke's 2004 indie film
before sunset enough of them will be
gone one day
[Music]
[Applause]